For this question we throw a ball straight up in the air at 20 m/s
I want to know what's the highest point above the ground that the ball reaches.
Now, this question is tricky in several ways.
Let's first try to identify our knowns, what was given to us.
Well, we threw it straight up with 20 m/s of velocity.
That's got to be the initial velocity,
because that's how fast it's going at the beginning of the problem.
Now, since this is a problem that's taking place on earth,
and the object is in free motion, I of course know the acceleration is 10 m/s².
But then I'm sort of stuck.
What is the highest point above the ground that the ball reaches?
Well, highest point seems important,
but I'm still a little confused and without a picture,
I'm not going to make much progress on this question.
So, let's draw a picture of what happens when you throw a ball straight in the air with some initial velocity.
Well, it goes up, up, up, up, up.
Eventually it stops and turns around and then comes back down.
Ah, okay, so this highest point, I can see is some sort of change in position.
The problem gives me the initial velocity, and I know the acceleration.
I'll need one more piece of information if I'm going to solve for Δx.
If you've been listening very carefully, I gave a hint.
Which of these two variables do we actually know when the ball is at the top of its trajectory?